Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I’m going to
explain the first part of a drama mini series
called “Click Bait,” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The beginning of the episode shows
us Andrea Brewer’s birthday party.
Her family has gathered to celebrate the
occasion. Her son Nick, daughter, Pia,
along with her Nick’s wife Sophie get Andrea
a birthday present. Pia is disappointed to see
that the present is a planter when she had
asked Sophie to get a bread maker instead.
She makes snarky comments to Sophie about
her ideas being lame. Nick gets mad at her
for disrespecting his wife and asks her to leave
the party immediately. Nick and Sophie’s sons,
Ethan and Kai look at the adults fighting in
horror. Pia embarrassingly leaves and goes to
a club. She drinks a lot and dances wildy to
forget what happened earlier. Sometime later,
she is in the club’s bathroom, texting a man named
Woody, who she matched on a dating app. She texts
him to meet her but accidentally drops her phone
in the toilet when she gets up to flush.
In the following scene, she is in her apartment,
putting her phone in rice so it would soak all the
water and repair itself. The next day, she drives
to the hospital where she works as a nurse. She is
assisting a patient as he shows her interesting
videos online to keep himself distracted. In one
of the videos, Pia’s brother Nick is holding
up a card that says "I abuse women." He then
holds up a different card that says "At 5 million
views I die." He seems to be beaten and scared,
as if someone is making him hold the signs. Pia
is shocked and doesn’t know what’s going on.
She rushes to the hospital’s phone to call Nick
but the call goes straight to voicemail. She then
calls Nick’s wife’s Sophie but she doesn’t pick up
either. Pia freaks out and rushes to Nick’s work.
She then asks his coworker Matt about him. Matt
claims that he hasn’t seen him since the morning.
Pia shows him the video which worries Matt, so
he asks his other coworker Dawn if she saw Nick.
The two find out that he missed his eight
oclock meeting and hasn’t been to work yet.
Pia is now more worried than ever, so she
rushes to the school where Sophie teaches.
She barges inside even when the guards warn her
not to. Sophie gets rid of the guard and watches
the video herself. She is as shocked as Pia to
watch it. According to her, Nick left for work
as usual in the morning, so the video makes
no sense. The two then go to the police to
file a missing report. On their way, the views in
Nick’s video reaches nine thousand and proceeds to
increase rapidly. The case is handled by a police
detective named Roshan Armiri. The detective asks
them several questions about Nick and focuses on
the part about him assaulting women. Sophie calmly
answers all his questions but Pia gets annoyed.
She and Roshan seem to know each other but do not
act on the fact. Sophie gets a call from her older
son Ethan and goes back home to them. The boys are
distressed to see the video of their father. Ethan
is on his tablet trying to access the “Find my
fam” app which might show where Nick is. However,
the app cannot find his location because his phone
is turned off. The video has reached three hundred
thousand views in just some hours and everyone in
the comments is calling Nick a monster. Sophie
tells the kids to not watch the video anymore
and stop going to school for the time being.
Pia returns back to her apartment to see that her
phone is finally working. She finds a voicemail
from Nick in which he apologizes for their fight
the previous day and says there are things he
needs to talk about with her. Pia plays the
voicemail on repeat while driving to her mother
Andrea’s house. She asks Andrea if she has talked
to Nick that day but Andrea says she hasn’t. Pia
opts to not tell her about the situation so she
wouldn't worry. Just then, she gets a text from
Sophie asking her to come to the police station
immediately. There, the two find out that another
video of Nick has been uploaded to the website.
In this one, he holds a card that says “I killed
a woman.” Since, the case has turned to homicide,
detective Roshan’s competitive colleague, Det.
Zach De Luca is added to investigate the case.
After watching the video, Pia immediately
recognizes that the first two signs were in Nick's
handwriting, the third one is not. Luca believes
that the video might be a confession and asks the
women if Nick is known to be violent. An enraged
Sophie tells him that Nick wouldn't hurt anyone,
man or woman. Pia also retaliates saying Nick is
the victim and the detectives should do something
before the video reaches five million views. When
Sophie and Pia come out of the police station,
Pia shows Sophie the voicemail she received and
asks her if she should show it to the police. But
Sophie wants to keep the mail on the low because
Nick sounds apologetic in it, which wouldn't help
their case as the police already suspect him to
be a murderer. As they talk, Sophie gets a call
from a journalist who wants to interview her.
The two get more nervous because of the call.
The video now has over a million and a half views.
A nervous Pia goes to her computer genius friend
Vince and asks him to somehow find Nick’s
location. Vince says that finding out Nick’s
location is beyond his reach but he has created
a subport where people from around the world
are investigating Nick’s case and helping to
look for him. Pia doesn’t believe that a mere
website can find her brother but appreciates the
help anyway. After that she makes way to Nick’s
house and is approached by a reporter outside. Pia
yells at her to stay out of the private property
and goes inside. A disappointed Andrea confronts
her for keeping Nick’s disappearance from her.
She apologises and checks up on
Nick’s son Ethan, who seems to be calm
and playing games at the time of crisis.
When Pia goes back to her apartment, the video has
made the news because of its popularity. Suddenly,
her hacker friend Vince arrives with important
information. The people in the subport have found
out that the video was taken in a specific kind
of delivery van by analysing the symbols in the
background. Pia thanks Vince and takes the proof
to the police. They begin to look for the specific
van through the traffic cameras while Pia waits
outside, accompanied by Nick’s coworker Matt.
After a while, she refreshes the website and
sees that the views have reached five million.
Just then, Roshan and the officers come outside
claiming that they have found the van.
Everyone quickly rushes to the location with
a SWAT team, only to find that the van is empty.
They search around the area but find nothing. At
last, the police conclude that Nick was not in the
van when it was disposed of. Back at the police
station, Luca assigns tasks to all the officers
involved in the case but excludes Roshan because
he is not from the homicide department, and his
services are no longer needed. When Roshan tries
to retaliate, Luca asks him to accompany Sophie
to her home. Outside her house, Sophie is mobbed
by the reporters. Roshan escorts her inside to see
that the house is being investigated for evidence.
Several police officers spread around looking
for anything significant clue that they can find.
The kids ask Sophie if Nick has been found
and she assures them he will be back soon.
Just then Luca arrives at the house and
seizes all the family members’ phones
so they can extract data that can
potentially help them with the case.
The family is skeptical about the procedure,
saying that they are being treated as suspects.
Everyone hands their phone except for Pia who
says that hers is at her apartment because it is
broken. Amidst the search, Pia goes out to smoke.
Roshan follows her behind for a chat. As the two
talk we find out that they have been chatting with
each other through a dating app for a long time.
In fact, before Pia’s phone dropped in the toilet,
she was planning to meet Roshan. She asks him to
keep her on the loop with anything that happens
with the case. However, Roshan reveals he has been
removed from it because he is from the missing
person department. He suggests Pia request the
sergant to put him on the case and Pia agrees.
Later, Roshan is searching the house on his own
when he sees Ethan in his room with a tablet.
Etahn says that it was his father’s old tablet
that no one uses anymore. Roshan still asks
for it to see if it has something important
but Etahn insists he needs it to monitor the
search. He explains that Nick’s case has grown
so popular that people have established an app
called “gionicking” dedicated to his search.
In the app, people go around areas in the city
where Nick can potentially be found and search
for him. The areas that have already been searched
are marked off the map in red. This peaks Roshan’s
interest and he takes the tablet for himself.
He then goes to the police station and shows
the app to the sergeant. But, she is not in the
favour of involving the civilians in the search.
Roshan also shows her the text messages that
were extracted from Ethan’s phone where he
talks about a big fight between his parents. When
Roshan walks outside of the sergeant’s office,
detective Luca condescendingly asks him to go
home. Roshan then makes his way to a sight that
hasn’t been searched through geonicking and
finds two teenagers searching for Nick’s body.
With no progress, Roshan visits the mosque and
then his home. His parents had seen him in the
news earlier and are proud of him for working in
such a big case. They ask him when he is going to
be promoted to the homicide department
but Roshan dismisses the question.
The following day, Sophie makes an
official statement to the reporters,
asking Nick’s kidnapers not to hurt him. Later,
Pia asks Roshan to meet her alone in his car
and shows him the voice message Nick had left her
before his disappearance. Roshan is annoyed at
her for not providing them with the information
sooner but Pia defends herself by saying they
can go through her phone now. He asks her what
“problem” Roshan wanted to talk to her about,
but Pia doesn’t know it either. Roshan then
goes to the sergeant and tells her about the
newfound information. He also comes clean of his
relationship with Pia before Nick’s disappearance.
After that, he returns back to his desk, only
to find the pictures from his dating profile
pasted all over his station. Luca laughs
at him for it. An enraged Roshan blames
him for being discriminatory towards him
because of his religion. But Luca claps
back saying that Roshan is not a team player
and is using this case to get promoted.
The next day, Nick’s bike is found by the side
of a secluded road. The police rush there and
investigate the scene. Soon, an empty syringe is
found nearby. They conclude that it was used to
kidnap Nick. After the investigation, Nick goes to
Sophie’s home and is received by her mother Ruby.
He informs the family about Nick’s bike
being found and asks to speak to Sophie
in private. He asks her about Nick’s voicemail
to Pia to which she reveals about their fight the
night prior. Then, Roshan inquires if Sophie and
Nick were facing some marital issues before his
disappearance. Sophie, unsettled by the question,
claims that the status of their relationship has
nothing to do with Nick’s disappearance. Roshan
gets suspicious and directly asks her if she
knows where her husband is. Sophie looks at him in
disbelief and asks him to get out of the house.
Next, he goes to Pia’s apartment to find her
observing the geonicking app. He asks her about
her fight with Nick only to be dismissed.
Eventually she tells them she and Nick are
closer than most siblings but he had been acting
differently for a few months. They got in a fight
because she called him out on it. She also reveals
that on March 16th, he came to her with bruises
and told her to keep it a secret from Sophie.
As they talk, the geonicking app shows Nick’s
body has been found. Roshan and Pia quickly
rush to the location where a crowd of people
surround Nick’s body. However, getting closer to
it, they see that the “body” is just a mannequin
with Nick's face pasted on it as a joke.
After the incident, Roshan drops Pia off at her
apartment where Nick’s co-worker Matt is waiting
for her outside. She and Matt go inside as Roshan
drives away. At night, the detective uses the find
my fam app to look where Nick was on 16th March.
He finds out he was at a bar and visits the
owner the following day. While watching the
CCTV footage, he sees that Nick had gotten into
a fight with an unknown man that day. Later,
he calls Pia to the police station and shows
her the video of the fight. Pia sighs of relief
that they finally have a lead and thanks Roshan
for working hard on the case. After Pia leaves,
Roshan presents his idea about the geonicking
to Luca who dismisses him at first but agrees
to go on a search anyway. They reach the woods
by an abandoned road where Roshan finally finds
Nick’s decaying dead body in a nearby river.
In the following scene, we see Roshan walk up to
Pia in her apartment and inform her of the
dead body being found. Even though Pia had
anticipated this, she breaks down crying
on the floor mourning her brother’s death.
The next day, Roshan is welcomed into the police
station with applause. The sergeant promotes him
to the homicide department and even Luca praises
him for his goodwork. He then helps his coworker
to go through Sophie’s socials. While working,
Roshan notices a picture of Sophie with a man
who looks like the guy Nick got into a fight
with at the bar. A surprised Roshan rechecks
and confirms that it is the same man.
In the following scene, we see Sophie at the
police station. Roshan officially informs her of
her husband’s death. She freezes on hearing the
news and asks the detective how he died. Luca
reveals that he had head trauma but the reason
hasn’t been confirmed yet. She sheds a single tear
and asks them who was responsible. Luca then shows
her the footage of Nick’s fight with the man and
asks Sophie if she knows him. To their surprise,
she lies and says she doesn’t. Then, she is
shown a picture of them together. Sophie finally
admits that the man is her former colleague named
Curtis Hamilton. She claims they are just friends
and coworkers but after her first lie,
the detectives find it hard to believe.
Later, she returns home and sits all of her
family down. She finally reveals to the kids
that their father is not returning home. All of
them burst into tears, grieving Nick’s death.
Then, we see Pia at the police station demanding
Roshan to let her see her brother’s body.
However, she is not allowed to see him until the
postmortem. Back in the house, Sophie tells her
mother that she was inquired about Curtis by
the police. When she reveals that she referred
to him as just a friend, her mother looks at her
in disbelief. It is clear that something was going
on in between the two. Sophie cries saying
that if Curtis is the one who killed Nick,
it will be her fault. As they talk, Pia arrives at
the house asking if she can sleep for the night.
Sophie invites her but doesn’t tell her anything
about Curtis. Then, we are shown the flashback of
Nick and Sophie’s last wedding anniversary. They
had a party that they enjoyed to the fullest.
But by the end of it, Sophie received a text
from curties that said he cannot stop thinking
about her. Sophie’s demeanor changed after
seeing the text. That night, she came clean
about her three months long affair with Curtis.
Nick was furious at her. Back in the present,
Sophie sneaks out of the house and goes to see
Curtis. He is shocked to see her but invites
her in. He acknowledges everything happening in
Sophie’s life and asks her if she is fine.
Sophie instead asks him why he met Nick
without telling her. Curtis replies that
Nick messaged him out of the blue and asked him
to meet at the bar. He wanted Curtis to tell
him every detail of their relationship; who was
interested first, when did they meet each other,
and how many times they made love. He claims that
by the end of the conversation, Nick attacked him,
but Sophie is suspicious of him. As they talk,
the police knock on his door and arrest Curtis.
It turns out they had been following Sophie
after she lied about her relationship earlier.
Both Curtis and Sophie are then taken to the
police station as suspects of Nick’s murder.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.